so good afternoon everyone I'm so glad
to see such a wonderful warm welcome to
our wonderful guest today Michelle Kwan
so this is a really beautiful splay of
space to be in to welcome our
distinguished chub fellow our a figure
skater Olympian and diplomat but before
we begin today's program I ask that you
turn off all your cell phones and
refrain from taking any photographs
during the program so that you do not
disrupt today's program so if you seated
just up front so you'll get to hear us
very well so those of you who don't know
me my name is Mary Lu I'm a professor in
the department of American Studies and
history and I am also the head of
college for Timothy Dwight College so as
the head of TD Timothy Dwight College I
have the honor of serving as the
custodian of the illustrious Chubb
fellowship that was established in 1941
out of a prior large donation for
education purposes made in 1936 by
Hendon Chubb a graduate of the Yale
class of 1895 since establishment the
Chubb fund has adhered to the goals of
providing encouragement and aid to
students interested in government and
American public affairs the fellowship
initially aimed to foster among Yale
undergraduates an interest in public
service in local and state affairs grew
over the years to include numerous
distinguished visitors in national and
international affairs as well as leaders
in the world of arts and the humanities
since the 1940s the Chubb fellowship
lecture series has inspired generations
of Yale students to undertake public
service and pursue leadership roles in
the hopes of creating a better world
today and for posterity the fellowship
has hosted four US presidents George HW
Bush Gerald Ford Jimmy Carter and Harry
Truman in recent years we have welcomed
the Y
range of national and international
leaders including visual artist faith
Ringgold environmental activist Bill
McKibben physician in humanitarian dr.
hawa Abdi former Secretary of
Transportation and commerce as well as
congressman Norman Mineta songwriter and
musician Paul Simon and world-renowned
actor Shahrukh Khan so it's quite a
distinguished list with this quick
description of the history and aims of
the Chubb fellowship I'm delighted that
we are welcoming to Yale today Michelle
Kwan the most decorated figure skater in
US history as our spring 2019 chub
fellow so Tavish al Kwan here on campus
is particularly meaningful to our
College Timothy Dwight College as it has
had a long history with skating in 1999
one of our students joanna pearl started
and became the president of what is now
the Yale Figure Skating Club our Dean
John Lodge served as the first faculty
adviser on record and the club engaged
in intercollegiate competition as well
as start a learn to skate program in the
local New Haven community at the Ralph
Walker rink in the East Rock
neighborhood and just a few years later
TD became the home of Sarah Hughes the
2002 gold medalists and women's figure
skating so the TD community is
particularly thrilled and proud to have
Michelle Kwan as their spring 2019 chub
fellow ma so pleased that we're joined
today by many distinguished guests from
across the university in particular I
wish to acknowledge Nathan Chen first
year student
so of course Nathan is not in TD it's
okay Nathan Jonathan Jonathan Edwards
College je and he just returned from
Japan after winning his second World
Championship
[Applause]
I'm also delighted that we have Vicky
Chun our new director of athletics with
us Vicky Chen began her position in July
2018 and she came to Yale after an
extraordinarily successful tenure as a
student athlete coach and vice president
and director of athletics at Colgate
University I'm thrilled to say that
she's the first woman and first
asian-american to serve in this very
important role at Yale
[Applause]
so it's a great honor to welcome
director Vicky Chun to the podium she
will be introducing our distinguished
chub fellow Michelle Kwan
[Applause]
while feeling a lot of Asian power right
now born and raised in California
Michelle Kwan a true sports icon into my
Asian family a living hero dominated
Figure Skating like no other US skater
from 1995 to 2005 she won an
unprecedented 43 championships including
five World Championships eight
consecutive and nine overall u.s.
national championships and two Olympic
medals in the nearly 100 year history of
US Figure Skating no American man or
woman has won more world titles national
titles or Olympic medals the US Olympic
Committee and others have celebrated
miss Kwan for her athletics
accomplishments and sportsmanship most
notable are 2003 US Olympic Committee
sports woman of the year 2001 Sullivan
Award as the top amateur athlete in
America 1998 World Sports Foundation
Sports woman of the year and in 2003
miss Kwan earned her seventh u.s. figure
skating skater of the Year award and
remains the only skater to have won the
award more than once in an unprecedented
move US Figure Skating renamed the award
in her honor it is now called the
Michelle Kwan trophy
[Applause]
off the ice miss Kwan has demonstrated
the important role a fleet scan play in
the world of public diplomacy furthering
opportunities for international cultural
dialogue and exchange in 2006 Secretary
of State Condoleezza Rice named Miss
Kwan America's first public diplomacy
envoy and senior advisor at the u.s.
Department of State working with the
Bureau of Education and Cultural Affairs
she continued that position under
President Barack Obama and was also
appointed to the President's Council on
Fitness Sports and nutrition in 2010 MS
Kwan was elected to the Board of
Directors a special olympics
international the organization's
ultimate governing authority responsible
for global affairs and strategies in
2011 she was named an advisor to the
us-china women's leadership exchange in
dialogue
MS Kwan graduated from the University of
Denver in November 2008 with the
Bachelors of Arts in international
studies and in May 2011 she received a
master's degree from the Fletcher School
of Law and Diplomacy at Tufts University
majoring in international relations in
January 2012 Michelle was ducted
inducted into the US Figure Skating Hall
of Fame the highest honor in US Figure
Skating in March 2012 michelle was
elected to the world figure skating
Hall of Fame and the only member the
only member of the class of 2012 that
same year she was selected by ESPN as
one of the 40 greatest female athletes
of the past 40 years please turn your
attention to this short video about
Michelle
Wow there's bill gage Stephen Hawking Co
McCartney Michael Jordan Michelle Kwan
they must be starting a new civilization
on Mars with our best and brightest
daddy's trip through the Piazza hala
yeah you're a real graceful man did you
know thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
we're doomed Texas let's see what
happens now in final jeopardy with the
category sports stars born in 1980 this
world champion figure skater was named
for a beatles hint who is Michelle Kwan
Michelle ma belle
and with that reception he Michelle Kwan
she is graceful
yeah yeah crazy crowd sudden death I
want go knows a silver I did it
[Applause]
[Music]
I've run out of superlatives long before
Michelle has run out of breathtaking
performances I think you're very classy
and I think you're a great asset to our
country make us all very proud the
people in the world who figure ski your
the best gift reaching the audience and
giving her soul to the audience and this
is one put together become one of the
greatest skaters and magnificent
[Music]
performance
[Applause]
Michelle it's a time of great
consequence in the world and I know that
you're going to play an important and
valuable role for our nation and now
ladies and gentlemen it is really with
great pleasure and great pride that I
present to you our first public
diplomacy envoy world champion figure
skater and University of Denver student
and a shelf on
[Applause]
I think we wanted to clap after every
scene please help me in welcoming
Michelle Kwan
[Applause]
when they watch videos I get a little
like I used to do that so crazy thank
you so much for the warm welcome
everybody
testing okay I'm working great so that
was a wonderful video and I think really
encapsulates your full career I think
there's a glimpse of you at the age of
nine maybe in in that quick montage of
all the skating that you've done so
you've had this amazing career as a
figure skater and so of course I have to
ask how did you get started in figure
skating what brought you to the sport I
started skiing when I was five years old
and part of that montage you know as the
Bart Simpson and the there's some sense
I think that was like the the pinnacle
because my brother supported me my older
brother supported me all along starting
from the age of five years old kind of
dragging me across the ice but when I
made it to the Simpsons he's like you
made it we made it but I started at five
years old and I just fell in love with
the sport it was a sport that you could
wear sparkly costumes you could go very
very fast and we have beautiful music
but it's also the athleticism of jumping
and I just loved it and I loved watching
skaters whip around and do triple jumps
and I think I never looked back from the
beginning of starting to skate at age
five to when I was seven years old and
watching the Olympic Games for the very
first time and it felt like yesterday
where I made this grand statement to my
family at seven watching dry boy Tata
wins the Olympics I said mom and dad I
know what I want to do for the rest of
my life I want to be an Olympic figure
skater but it at that time it's like
okay I thought it was going to be easy I
thought you liked fine a little like
piece of paper saying I'm going to the
Olympics
right now but it takes a lot of hard
work and my parents were so dedicated
they sacrifice so much but help provide
that opportunity for for me this game so
you started a5 and then you start to
enter into competitions and then before
you knew it you were winning some of
them and that you were been competing on
the national level so at what point did
your family realize wait this is not
just you know a little girl having these
sort of Disney fantasy's but this is
something that may actually be the
future well it was gradual I think my
parents wishes in my skating career or
when I was really young was perhaps you
get good enough to get a scholarship or
perhaps it will stand out if you apply
for colleges because I think my parents
were forward-thinking in the sense that
they knew they wouldn't be able to
afford three kids at school so be good
at something take up a hobby play go to
gymnastics do extracurricular activities
keep yourself very busy but as I started
to skate I was like completely in love
with it was like only thing I was
thinking about it really was the age of
nine ten and that I started to get my
triple drums and I started to metal did
my parents really go wow this is
something we're it it could be something
but I think the championship that I was
I was 12 years old I won the Olympic
Festival and that was the one that was
like in front of over 20,000 people
watching watching and still to this day
like the biggest audience at the
Alamodome that has ever watched skating
competition that my parents are ago
we're gonna pay attention now not that
they weren't there was a hobby now
something taken really seriously and
then at the age of 13 years old I
was I was silver medalists at the 94
national championship and this is the
year if you remember was the Tonya
Harding Nancy Kerrigan I see a few nods
I think some people are too young or
they were not born then but I was I was
silver behind Tonya Harding and a lot of
people don't know that I was actually
behind Nancy Kerrigan when she was
attacked Kerrigan Kwan's same warm-up
like six skaters in each warm-up and it
was something that was captured by the
cameras and then I was really kind of
thrust into the spotlight during that
year and unfortunately I wasn't sent as
part of the Olympic team but it was kind
of sent as an alternate just in case
something and something was always
happening from January to February were
the Nationals to the Olympics it's
happening so I was kind of so from 13 on
it it seemed to be my life really so did
you have any moments where you thought
what is this crazy life I've put myself
into and thought about leaving quitting
the sport or what are some things that
you would say we're really serious
obstacles or challenges I think
throughout my my skating career I was I
was very lucky that I didn't have a lot
of injuries I stayed on top of my game
for over a decade there were challenges
especially when I went it was Olympic
year and here was my foot in a cast
I had a stress fracture in my second
metatarsal and it was the most
devastating blow you know you you're
seven years old you're dreaming of going
to the Olympics and then you finally
turn 17 you're now 16 you're world
champion and it's your moment to go to
the Olympics and here I was a few months
before didn't the Nationals in a cast
and it was a pivotal moment because I
looked at this moment as a real lesson
learned because there was two ways I
could do it
I could quit because I was really in a
situation that I couldn't train I
couldn't do anything the doctor said I
couldn't train to like three weeks
before the national championships and so
I was I was a little emotional I didn't
know what to do I said okay I could quit
now or I could just approach it like
with a good attitude and and really say
what the heck I'm just gonna go for it
and those with the Nationals that I had
a lot of 6.0 which is a perfect score
and then qualified won those
championship and made it to the Olympics
so sometimes I take those lessons
learned in sports and we're you know
sometimes you are your back is against
the wall and you're going okay well I
could just be like throw in the towel or
I could just lean in have a smile on my
face and you're like it is the way it is
and I'm just gonna have a good attitude
and do my very best and sometimes that's
good enough so what would you you've had
so many awards and performances and
clearly from the montage we saw and many
that we didn't even show what are some
of the most memorable of these would you
say what stands out in your mind as
something that you always will treasure
as the remarkable accomplishment in your
career there have been so many
incredible moments but the one that was
part of that montage was when I was
wearing a gold costume it was the
Olympic year in 2002 I was skiing two
fields of gold and I had gold costume
but it was ironic because I won the
silver but it is one of the most
memorable moments in my life because it
was such a devastating thing because I
you always in your life always want to
be the best and of course when I was
dreaming and watched Brian Boitano win
the Olympics I was wanting not just
participate but I want a drug winning
the gold but in 2002
actually it was Bronzeville medalist I I
don't know it finishing the long program
and then the next day you have the
exhibition sorry things like you know
not having that whirlwind and then you
have an exhibition the following day and
I I looked at it and it was so beautiful
because here I was the Olympics in Salt
Lake City you know in the United States
and wearing Team USA uniform all this
and then I skated I was like this is the
most beautiful thing like despite not
having my dreams completely true like
beautiful like it would have been
beautiful if I'd won the gold scape two
fields of gold skating gold costume with
Vera Wang costume I mean it would have
been just like perfect right but I just
skated around and I had emotional tears
like and they weren't pretty there were
the snotty tears they're like and I'm
going into a triple lutz and I could
barely see like it was this like joy /
beauty and everything rolled into one
where I knew my place I knew wasn't
about winning the gold it was about what
I was doing and it was doing what I love
every day yeah we talked a little bit
before today's conversation about what
it means to be a role model and I think
what you're saying just now sort of
epitomizes that it isn't necessarily
about winning every single competition
out there but truly showing the
expressions of joy and love of the sport
and the the moment so you also said it
was just very funny to be suddenly
thrusted into this position of role
model at the age of 13 so I'm curious to
hear you say more about that yeah we
were talking about earlier about you
know there are some athletes that really
say oh you know what I'm not a role
model why is it and there's it's it
really disappoints me to the core I was
kind of stressed in the limelight at 13
and I'll remember it like it was
yesterday where
a young mom with her five-year-old
daughter was like my my daughter skates
around the living room and all she wants
to be is you you're you're her role
model and I'm like I'm 13 years I don't
know when you think I don't know how I
can but I think from that moment I said
well I'm just gonna be the best daughter
I can be and be best dude and I can be I
am best you know a skater that I can be
and hopefully I I make mistakes it's
it's only human but that was something
that I I took very seriously as I was
going through the ranks and like over
the years people say you know my
daughter and my son look up to you and I
take that responsibility seriously and I
hope when I look at like future
generations and I see great role models
like Nathan it is incredible at the
generation after them are so lucky to
have these incredible role models like I
had Brian Boitano that I really really
admired from afar since I was seven
years old and then at 13 when I was kind
of thrust into everything I had a chance
to get to know him I I toured on this
tour called champions on ice and he
really took me under his wing and we had
the same kind of training mentality the
same almost it was it was a little
strange because we even warmed up the
same or similar way and really picked
his brain about the Olympics what was it
like and he was he was right there and
so he became a mentor and and a dear
friend so being a role model and
certainly being world champion and then
participating in the Olympics two
Olympics you know you had to present--
the United States so I want to hear a
little bit about that so did you think
of yourself as you were competing in
these international venues that you were
representing the United States always or
did you mostly think I'm here to compete
in this what seems like a very solo
sport in many ways yeah you're very
serious right when you go to a
competition you're at the hotel and you
are at the ice rink right it's like you
don't see much you're not there
sightseeing and doing touristy things
you're it's your you have your game face
on and the responsibility is also more
extreme especially when you're your head
to toe and Team USA I mean I'm very
patriotic and I'm representing and I
know that responsibility especially at
the World Championships or the Olympic
Games where you're at the opening
ceremonies and you're walking behind the
American flag with your fellow teammates
you have that pride and that that that
sense of responsibility but at the same
time when you're skating you're like
you're completely focused so I think
you're kind of twofold I guess you're
hmm you're you know you're representing
but you have to go out there and deliver
and and attempt to try to make everyone
proud did you ever feel there were at
all conflicts or contradictions of being
a figure skater and Olympian and
representative Team USA or did all those
roles just meld in beautifully for you
it really was it was all one so in 2006
as we saw in the closing of the video
you stepped away from the sport of ice
skating and entered this new world
literally because new world is of being
the public envoy the public diplomat as
appointed by then Secretary of State
Condoleezza Rice so please take us
through that how did that happen yeah a
lot of people are like how did you go
from here to diplomacy interested in
international relations and in hindsight
now it kind of it sort of makes sense
the path sort of kind of lends itself to
be where I am but let me tell you it was
it was a very interesting trend
from sports completely focused on only
one thing and that was to get better and
stronger as an athlete but then knowing
that I represented the United States and
was so honored to in Olympic Games and
World Championships the International
Grand Prix but it's it was similar in
some regard when I was appointed as the
first public diplomacy envoy by
Secretary Rice and I I do want to go
back how that all came about when I
speak to young people I always say don't
be shy to connect with people don't be
shy to ask questions or say something or
what you're curious about don't feel shy
to intern or get to know more right
and I happened to be invited to a state
dinner where it was president who Jintao
and President Bush and secretary
Condoleezza Rice and I I didn't know
that I was going to be at the head table
in fact at the receiving line it was
like shaking hands and then President
Bush said oh by the way you're sitting
next to us
next to me actually we're gonna be
talking about some really serious
foreign policy issues and I really and
I'm like that's why I've got like like
what am I gonna say what you know
thinking like how I can't answer to
anything I don't know so i sat there was
it was great was that Yi's was a nice
lunch and then I had the opportunity to
say hello to secretary of rice and she's
a pianist and a lot of people don't know
that she she was a former figure skater
as well and I connected them that way
and then I also told her that there's a
possibility I'll be a pioneer like her
where her alma mater was University of
Denver her adviser was Josef Korbel
founder of the GSIS School the
International study school and is also
the father of secretary Madeleine
Albright so we connected we talked and
at this very brief I'm I think it was
five minutes but why five seconds
I said if if there's anything that I can
do to help I don't I mean like Here I am
a figure skater asking like the
secretary if there's anything I could
help let me know but it got the ball
rolling in a conversation where she said
there's this would love to import you as
a envoy a public diplomacy envoy and
where it opened my eyes to international
relations at the same time I did end up
going to the University of Denver and I
had the opportunity to travel as an
envoy it was sort of my internship to to
be an odd way and also to learn more
about diplomacy and study and one thing
kind of led to another I ended up
pursuing my master's degree after and
and furthering my education so that's
how I ended up in that situation so I
always tell students I'm like whether
it's your elevator pitch or whether it's
like trying to connect folks don't be
shy I'm usually the one that doesn't
speak up I'd ever raise my hand I'm more
of an introvert in that scale but I did
that one time and she has become like
why wait I know somebody I looked up to
but has become a mentor and a golf buddy
now so you never know in life right I'm
sitting right here at Yale so I yeah so
one of the things that I think we we
talked about is how your experience as a
competitor and the most elite levels of
your sport there are some very important
skills while you can't do a triple toe
during diplomatic conferences you know
but that said there are other kinds of
wonderful skills and lessons that you
took from your sport and that you've
moved into the world with diplomacy so
can you speak a little bit about that
yeah I always have sort of sports
analogies and I always go back to what I
learned in skating and sometimes there
were
hard lessons like I've learned hard work
yeah I knew that it wasn't as simple as
signing up and going to the Olympics I
knew that you had to put in the hours I
knew that sometimes you fall and
sometimes you fall in front of millions
of people but you have to pick yourself
back up and persevere and those life
lessons was something that I succeeded
in sports but I applied to succeed
outside like I going to grad school to
me was this like my parents were like
what you're applying to grad school
there's no I think it was like scary for
me was probably one of the scariest
things I did because I was a lot older I
was 29 28 29 and I was thinking of all
the years that people were going to
school and in the library the hours I
spent in on the ice they were they're so
far ahead so I was like playing catch-up
all the time but then I was like but
there are some key lessons that I
learned in sports like hard work and I I
know I might be behind but I can like
put myself I know how to apply myself so
I didn't feel like I was starting from
zero so just to be clear you were
balancing a full academic load while
being a public diplomat is this right
yes so I was traveling as an envoy and
traveling but it was like I said sort of
an experience that I had the opportunity
to meet such incredible Foreign Service
officers public affairs officers
diplomats civil servants within State
Department that it really got my like I
had this at my fingertips exposed to
this and so at grad school I had applied
to the White House fellowship which is a
very prestigious fellowship it's
mid-career so it was a little I was in
grad school but it was mid-career so I
went through that process unfortunately
I didn't get the fellowship but I sort
of
kind of reached out and was also on a
listening tour because I was had I had
access to certain people and I I made
the most of it and so it was it was a
learning experience and that led to
working at the State Department
eventually not as an envoy but as one of
the senior advisors there this was your
time in the Bureau of cultural and
educational affairs so tell me a little
bit more about the kinds of programs and
projects you created there well I have
to give you a little snippet so after I
graduated from Fletcher like like any
student or like some students it's like
what do I do now it's like okay how do I
go about getting a job like what does
that mean and how do I apply like I knew
that I knew the process but I DC and I
had really enjoyed working alongside
many like I said many people at the
State Department and I didn't know sort
of how and where but I ended up at the
Department of State at the bureau of
educational affairs Cultural Affairs and
it was it was a nice and very
interesting thing that happened because
as I was traveling as an envoy I saw it
as sort of a micro level where I was
connecting and I was connecting to
students and talking about educational
social issues and answering questions
and there was a incredible exchange and
at the same time when I was working as
an advisor I was helping more behind the
scenes broadening the scope of our
exchange programs whether that's music
or Fulbright or sports diplomacy which
to me was the coolest and that was the
thing that was so interesting was that I
saw in the micro and then a macro level
where I was more behind the scenes to
try and find funding all the
nitty-gritty things of
improving sort of certain initiatives
and things that we were pushing forward
so what do you see as very unique or
wonderful about sports diplomacy that's
that's particularly wonderful in terms
of allowing for meaningful international
exchange well though one thing I'd have
to say that of course in Figure saying
it's like using sports to break the ice
like it really is because it's despite
differences of race gender sex really it
doesn't matter you could have somebody
wearing green somebody this way somebody
all these differences are such are put
aside when you're talking sports it's
it's incredible first of all when you're
talking to students or kids it's like
they weren't paying attention and then
suddenly Cal Ripken or somebody and let
Ellen DeGeneres is also an envoy
suddenly people listen and it's a
two-way street so you you're there
you're answering questions and some of
the misconceptions that they might have
about American so it's it was such a fun
and a unique experience and I met a lot
of incredible people
so aside from your official work with
the State Department these different
capacities in recent years you've spent
time working on a number of political
campaigns so you you've really continued
to move deep into the world of politics
so tell us more about that movement yeah
well first of all I never thought that
I'd be in politics at all
I still say I'm not in politics but I
had the opportunity and honor to work
for Secretary Clinton and saw firsthand
her leadership
when I had friend I had friends that
were at the chief protocol different
areas within the State Department and I
saw they were sort of going to her
personal office and it was getting
larger and larger and there were rumors
whether or not she was going to run and
so I called a couple of my friends and
is this happening is this is she running
I'd love to help out in some capacity
and so it started to real come together
and I started working in Brooklyn her
headquarters five days before her
announcement at Roosevelt Island so I
was her surrogate outreach coordinator
surrogates are basically people who I
mean it is Hillary can't be everywhere
so I had I worked with celebrities
members of Congress and it was a very
unique opportunity and and also a fun
experience so how did you see again your
experience as an athlete and then an
envoy coming into play well during the
campaign I definitely if anybody has
worked on a campaign it's there's a lot
of fires it's like there's always
something happening at a time so as an
athlete they're always you always put in
tough situations but somehow you're able
to take a deep breath and step back a
little bit and analyze the situation and
deal with it accordingly and there's
always a fire somewhere so I think
during the campaign when there are a lot
of things that happened
I won't specifically talk about certain
things certain days but where everyone's
like yelling and screaming and we're
like we're all just like okay looks like
what is the solution to this challenge
and I think that's an athlete those are
the thing types of situations you're in
you're like it really helps to know your
body awareness and more self-aware and
handle how to handle situations and I
think my experience at school and grad
school was also it came in handy and
also the things that I learned that grad
school came in handy
and how to deal with situations and
reach out to people and find solutions
so of course another passion and
committed work that you would do is
around Special Olympics you just got
back from Abu Dhabi from the World Games
and of course you came back to questions
around funding yeah so that was
interesting last week yes so I have been
involved with Special Olympics for the
past ten years I volunteered as a kid
working with Special Olympic athletes
figure skaters and I just volunteered
and over the years I got more and more
involved and I see this organization as
like part of my family I don't see it as
volunteering it's like you do this for
your brother you do this for your mom or
do this for your family this
organization got was founded 50 years
ago by eunice Kennedy Shriver a lot of
people don't know President JFK had a
sister rosemary that had been told this
in intellectual disabilities so it went
from backyard to now the scope of sort
of the Olympic Games where we have the
World Games and we switch summer in
winter every two years and so our recent
one was at in Abu Dhabi and we had
75,000 7,500 athletes a hundred and
ninety two countries participated and
it's not only through sports it's it's
also healthy athletes one of the things
that we have is sort of health care we
have doctors who volunteer their time
and they do basic screening of you know
help like dental hearing and just very
very basic few hours they go through it
but what a lot of people don't know
about people with intellectual
disabilities a lot of perception is that
they have better health care or
but in some cases our athletes don't
have the most basic like have never seen
a doctor before stories where you have
our athletes talking about how Special
Olympics changed their lives by having a
community of friends and where most
people with intellectual disabilities
are made fun of or isolated or excluded
or they're just not included and the
healthy athletes it's health care where
it has saved many people's lives
Dustin Plunkett who's a dear friend of
mine is also athlete but he tells the
story of how he went through healthy
athletes and just very preliminary he he
found that he had cancer mouth cancer
and so to me as this organized
organization this movement grows it went
from the backyard to now helping six
million people with intellectual
disabilities and their families not
helping but creating this movement I
also know that there are so many more
people wanting to be involved and to be
included and having a chance to play and
grow and like I said you learned so much
through sports but you can also learn
through sports and also grow as a person
and so Special Olympics as you could
tell me it's a lot to me every time I'm
with the athletes and the fact their
families it's like I get really
emotional and when I was in Abu Dhabi I
didn't expected it was one of our global
ambassadors I actually a couple of them
they were introducing themselves and
ones from Pakistan ones from Canada ones
from and the 17 year old I say boy he
said I didn't know how I didn't learn
how to speak till I was eight and you're
just like and then the the global
ambassador from Hawaii
yes I had similar obstacles and then she
said her similar obstacles and then
somebody said well the introductions
aren't over the global investor ye is
gonna say a few more things and then she
burst into singing and it is this is us
and I I just lost it
I mean they they teach me so much about
the human spirit about passion and love
and and when I got involved in Special
Olympics I thought oh this is it's great
to volunteer but then it became
something that I'm really passionate
about so your outlook on funding oh oh
yeah that part I actually got a number
of calls to do interviews and I was like
because it means so much and to hear
there were budget cuts slashed to sum to
my family this is this is an
organization that I really care about
and 17 million dollars and it's a
bipartisan support and organization and
this these resources are so vital in
terms of what we call like we want more
inclusion but we can't do it if we don't
have resources that are getting into
schools across the country or we are
doing programs called unified sports
where we have people with and without
intellectual disabilities playing
together and really the idea is that if
you work together if you study together
if you play together
you're more inclusive and and then
people that have never been in touch
with anybody with intellectual
disabilities they start to build better
understanding and and that's where you
have more inclusion you have so when I
heard about the budget cuts I was like a
gasp and then when it was rescinded I
was like you know it was a very
emotional emotional time for Special
Olympics in the last week but what chair
our chairman Tim Shriver said it was
like this is
his unity this is this is about the
human spirit this is about helping one
another and then he said it so
beautifully and it is it's helping one
another out and Special Olympics needs
that and you know you take a situation
like the 94 Olympics the whole incident
you take a situation like last week but
in some ways there's a there's a good
thing that came out of it you know it
was at the forefront of national news
and it really we had supporters come out
from all walks of life different you
know Republican Democrat everyone
we had athletes writing letters to their
representatives saying you know we need
these programs so and it really became
this kind of like really special moment
that came out of it where we're strong
and we're gonna continue our mission
great so this is gonna be my last
question and I think we're gonna open it
up to the audience for you all to have
an opportunity to ask questions of
Michelle so I guess the proper ending
question is what next for you what is
going to be the new newest project
endeavour I told you not to ask me I
don't know although there is a
possibility that I will help a
presidential candidate so that will be a
busy time mm-hmm okay I think we'll
leave it at that okay I have nothing
else to say to that
all right the floor is open I have to
AIDS who are walking around with
microphones so if you would like to ask
a question please just raise your hand
and one of them will get to you hi
Michelle my name is Caitlin card and I'm
a senior here at Yale one question that
I have is in all of your different roles
whether it's an Olympian or a diplomat
or student what are some of your
attributes your own personal attributes
or even support systems in place that
have really aided in your success hmm
characteristics I guess
I would say I'm pretty scrappy and that
doesn't sound really Pleasant right I
mean scrappy and the way I what I mean
by that is that there were so many times
that I had to quit skating because my
parents couldn't make ends meet and I
sometimes have to put myself in their
position where they're struggling to put
a roof over our heads and first of all
they immigrated to the United States
with nothing and I think of courage when
I think of my parents like nothing not a
my dad didn't graduate from high school
he still to the States as I speak
English because his Cantonese is Luna
and there's English and sometimes he's
very hard to understand so they
immigrated to United States with nothing
and and struggled a lot and there were
times where it was so expensive you know
lessons are very expensive ice time our
equipment it's I think anybody who plays
sports will not be like this is and I
think my parents at times had to be very
upfront with me and said well I don't
know if you'll get the opportunity to
and like skate anymore because you're
you've grown your skates and I don't
know where the next pair of skates is
going to come from we'll just have to
see and and my parents you know and I
have to give a shout out to like women's
Sports Foundation some individuals that
really were helpful in my career that I
received a travel training grant for
example that helped provide that next
pair of skates or that next pair of
youth skates
to have that opportunity and going back
to that word scrappy is that I didn't
have the nicest costumes I didn't have
the custom skates although my dad said
they were customs and I I said dad how
are they custom
if I didn't ever know one measured my
feet know one and then getting the
custom skates and I turned it upside
down and it had the skaters name on it
crossed out my dad had written in
michelle i have the escapes and they're
like my most prized like my third mine
anyways but I didn't have the prettiest
costumes I in fact at the 93 Nationals
when I was junior I was
I borrowed a costume from a fellow
skater and they didn't go with the cup
you know the music whatever but I was
there I made it actually all the way
that national championships without a
coach and that's when I actually meant
Frank Harrell two weeks I would say
between sectionals and Nationals it's a
few weeks and then worked with Frank
Carroll who became my coach for over ten
years but I was lucky did be in touch
with him and then also at the same time
gets support from ice castle and have
free room and board and have free meals
and free ice time and then the thing
that cost a lot was coaching but because
you know everything was provided for
except lessons my parents can you know
continue allow me to continue my dreams
so that's that's how I see it I was a
little Scotty and persevering and I'm a
little hard-headed so I think a scrappy
person it's a little harder they just
kind of I'll get there somehow and I'll
make it I'll make it do
hi my name is Erica I'm a master student
here and I first of all want to say I'm
definitely not the only one who's like
has the gold outfit and feels a gold bar
to the brain I definitely vividly
remember watching that as a kid so thank
you for that moment but my question is
so given that you've worn so many hats
and given our global social media world
right now
what was it like befriended Jonathan
Venice so I didn't know some of you
might not know who Jonathan Venice but
if you seek where I he is one of those
superstars there and who is a skating
prodigy who just started to learn how to
skate he's a hairdresser but he is a
jack-of-all-trades
like he is now I'm actually gonna go to
New York to see him he has a stand-up
comedy show and he's gonna do stand-up
in Radio City Music Hall but he is
somebody that we pretended I mean this
day and age I do yeah I got became
friends with him on Instagram like I
started following him and then he posted
something he was like I was like oh was
that a mistake I can't unfollow Kate I
guess but we just really hit it off and
actually last week it was his birthday
and he was attending the GLAAD Awards
where the queer I was nominated and he
asked me to be his date and it was he's
such a doll and I have to say like what
I wore was the sequin he's like sparkly
like sparkles everywhere outfit and it's
a dress long-sleeved but I I was
laughing because as I was going to the
red carpet he's like who are you wearing
and I'm like I'm wearing Jonathan's
sweater I don't know who but he told me
as I walked in he's like we're gonna get
glam
and I was like okay so he we met and he
has a team of hairstylist which he he
helped with my hair and didn't make up
and there's like there's a bunch of
costumes and the costumes but outfits
for him to consider and when I walked in
I was like this beautiful like black
dress it's classy sophisticated
it is the glad words it's LGBTQ amor you
you better like it he gave me this
sparkly thing and I said that's just
sweater that's like tried it on but it
worked his stylist went out grabbed a
pair of silver shoes and and and
something else but it was it was a lot
of fun so I have had become really good
friends with him and he he's giving me
pointers on social media he's giving
because I when I was competing we didn't
have Instagram we didn't have twitter we
didn't have like now it's like nice to
be able to follow Nathan and figure out
what he's eating before he competes or
what is what is he doing after you won
the World Championship
oh he's going back to Yale and he's
taking his midterms oh my god so yeah
I'm learning a lot and like Jonathan is
he's he's very sassy on all of it do you
have any aspirations of running for
Senate for Senate
no I am being I've seen it so close up
now okay that was that I don't know I at
the moment I'm just I want to be behind
the scenes helping and I to be a
politician to have to fundraise and to
do all that it's it's a lot of work but
it's so meaningful you know being able
to make a difference and be a voice for
those
don't have a voice and being in a place
where you hear people talking about the
challenges that they face and trying to
come up with a solution so and we never
say no but not at the moment no
aspirations
hi Michele thank you for sharing your
experience with us today a me me I'm Evy
Funke Timothy Dwight College I have a
question regarding the new rules so we
know that is you announced a couple of
new rules at the end of last year for
example the increase of grade of
execution cut at the time for free free
program for men and pears what are some
far-reaching effects that you think
those changes are going to bring to the
programs for example choreography thank
you thank you
it's very skating specific and you know
as I was joking with you earlier I was
like I've been so out of the loop that I
didn't I don't the judging specific
judging and when they altered him like I
really know I have to actually make fun
of myself because Angela wearing a
skater that has the championship level
she said can you help choreograph a
program for me I said no I really don't
know the rules that well and it's so
complicated you have a grade of
execution you have this and it's all
these layers that you have to basically
like gymnastics count what is what is
worth what and so it's really you have
to be very smart in approaching how you
choreograph a program these days but I
was laughing with Angela because I
agreed I said well if you working with
my sister and we come up with music then
I'll help you I'm not gonna choreograph
I could just be like yes that looks good
no this was rework this and I said well
where's the spiral sequence
it's like Michelle they got rid of that
like years ago like where where are you
so with to your question I I think it's
really hard for skaters and
choreographers and and their team to
choreograph programs because so many
things is calculated and it has become
very hard because you're your cow
and some some things like the donut spin
or the B lemon spin is like where you
put the blade like to your head and I
just physically know because I when they
changed the system it was actually the
year I was like actually stepping out of
competing and retiring and it I'm
lucky because I physically was trying to
learn abby'll min and spin with Tatiana
Tarasova and here she was like trying to
put my leg next my head and I was like
it just doesn't do that anymore like I
hear I like and at 26 I'm like old I'm
like a grandma you know I'm old and and
that was the thing that I like struggled
but knew that if I had to compete at
that level you had to do the elements
that had maximized the points so that
was like the thing that I kind of fought
against so sometimes choreography and
musicality is compromised because I have
to do the spin and it's really
uncomfortable and I can't do it but it's
worth for but whatever points it is but
I do applaud those artists rate the
skaters that can bring the artistry and
the elements and the quadruple John's
like Nathan when I watched your free
skate I was like this is this is where
it is the most magical combination where
someone can do quadruple odds quadruple
flip and to be honest when I first heard
of you doing that I was like no no no
way
then my sister sent me like video clips
and I was like I had to rewatch it and
put it in slow motion like I never
thought it was humanly possible and he
has to do all the elements of like the
footwork where you have to be like highs
and lows like body and I'm like I know
what where and where the spins and this
is so sad that I'm admitting this but
like where I you have to have seven
revolutions or six revolutions back in
my day but I was like camel spin breathe
1 2 3 4 5
six and then nowadays it's like you have
to be in these crazy positions and you
can't breathe when you're like your
body's contortion to like a wet so I see
that and I'm like I applaud those
skaters that can bring the artistry the
musicality and the athleticism of all
these quadruple drums and and also go to
Yale Michelle I've been a fan of yours
since 1994 the first time you skated at
the old Hartford Civic Center with the
Stars on ice or we're champions on ice
program so I've been following your
career since then I'm an adult skater
I didn't start skating thought I was
about 46 years old and I've already
touched base with Nathan and he said yes
he'll give me a lesson up at champions
or at Cromwell I thought maybe you could
join us
yeah I could use a little help but my
real question is that when I look back
at your skating my favorite program was
East of Eden both the long program and
the short program do you remember that
program as well as you remember fields
of gold with the gold dress and all or
or do you forget those programs or you
know to be Jonathan Vanessa knows all my
programs he knows all the current
skaters he knows but East of Eden was a
program that I I fell in love with the
music and I thought it was really
difficult because it was slow throughout
and I was like how can I maintain the
program throughout the program I mean
throughout that time were the tempo
because in the long program is four
minutes and you have fast section in
your slow section and you're like oh
this is where the footwork will be and
this is where the sequence or where now
doesn't exist is that so I when I
choreograph a program with my
choreography the help of the
choreographer like Laureen Nick Laura
Nichols nikolai morozov i really pay
attention to the music because i have to
love it and because we listen to it 1
million
times I better really like the music so
beautiful that was such a thank you and
I also there's a you you you can be
creative in skating you can be part of
like the designing of costumes and Frank
Carroll really liked a program or a
costume of Linda Friday on a world
champion figure skater who he coached
and the costume was won one of the
costumes that a Vesuvian was inspired by
Linda Friday awnings costumes yeah thank
you I am a grad student here at Yale and
I've been lucky enough to skate at Yale
all five years of my PhD and Counting
and so being a figure skater you've
entered you've obviously interacted with
a lot of Russians either coaches
choreographers fellow competitors and
I'm just wondering as somebody who is
both a figure skater and also interested
in diplomacy how do you feel about the
current you know our politically the US
and Russia have always had kind of a
rocky relationship and it's kind of
getting worse recently but that
relationship at the big country level
isn't necessary doesn't necessarily
reflect how Americans and Russians get
along with one another and where do you
see potentially the role of sports and
in particular figure skating in sort of
breaking down barriers and forming bonds
wow that's a a very hard well I can say
from my travels as an envoy Russia was
one country that I traveled as an envoy
and I was very lucky as we were talking
like sort of the experiences that I had
when I traveled as an envoy I could
easily defer some of the difficult
questions whether was sort of the
anti-american or
you know perceptions of our current
administration or our and even meanwhile
I'm sitting here I'm very conscious of
like not going very political here but
it we all have our various views but one
thing that is difficult in the most
recent findings of the the report it's
like the collusion of Russia and
us-russian relations so it's it's a I
have a lot of opinions on it and
probably not in this forum that I should
say anything but it is hard because when
you have meddling in in in our elections
then it becomes a concern and how it
could have played a part in the election
and I hope I always have hope that in
2020 will not it will be democracy at
its best as opposed to anybody anybody
any country meddling and in our
democracy
hi I'm Kat I'm a second year MFA
directing candidate at the Yale School
of Drama often my question is oftentimes
Asian Americans deal with difficulty
being seen and treated as Americans and
I was wondering especially being a
representative of the u.s. in so many
ways for so many years how have you
dealt with that challenge if you have I
wasn't thinking of bringing this up but
to your question I was competing at
Nagano where you know the world
champions was just that in Japan I was
super look for looking forward to it
it's like a an honor you make it to the
Olympics and you have a lot of press on
you and you have what is like a pool of
press so you do your practice and this
is every practice you do your practice
and then you kind of walk through and
you had the Chicago Tribune you know the
Christine Brennan is the Phil Hirsch the
you know the group of Chicago Tribune LA
Times New York and I don't know in the
mix of questions was oh you're so close
to home how does it feel and I was like
well first of all I'm American as I'm
wearing a team USA and I'm so honored to
be here representing the United States
of America and clearly like speaks
English you know and it was frustrating
because he kept on going back to life
but your parents heritage and I said no
I'm very like I'm proud of my Chinese
heritage I speak Cantonese I celebrate
Chinese holidays like Chinese New Year's
and the home bow and I but I'm very much
American it was frustrating I think at
times especially that specific in
but overall I I didn't run into too much
because I was so proud and so patriotic
to represent the United States since the
age of 13 all the way to 26 so but that
that came to mind at one moment and you
kind of just kind of ignore and you kind
of stay true to who you are what you
represent I think this is our last
question
well to be honest I really don't know
just a few years ago or when my sister
sent me YouTube clips of Nathan I didn't
think doing a quad lots was physically
possible like I did not think that it
would be to level where he's skating and
then just as the reason I saw something
with kristi yamaguchi skating show where
she was being honored Alyssa Liu who's
our national champion who's 13 years old
doing a quadruple lutz and I said this
is how long has she been working on this
how is this physically possible to do
and I have to admit that I actually
watched it a couple of times more than a
few times going this is this is so I can
sir your question I have no idea but it
might be the Nathan you might want to
ask Nathan or Alyssa that because I
don't know what's capable I don't know
what he's working on it yeah like I at
you could you might like set up a camera
and to spy on what he's working on
because I'd be curious to know not to
encourage you to do that sorry but it's
it's awesome it's an incredible time and
I see it develop and I see the things
that nathan is doing a see Alyssa
who is this incredible 13 year old who
just won it is our future of us figure
skating is so bright and I actually I
sent Nathan a message because he was
like skateboarding around campus I was
like be careful I was being the more the
grass well I think on that wonderful
note especially with your pronouncement
that the future of US Figure Skating is
very bright and limitless I think this
is a great place to end so please join
me in thanking
[Applause]